on entend beaucoup parler et encore plus
depuis la pandémie d'autosuffisance
alimentaire certains en rêvent d'autres
la pratique à petit échelle aujourd'hui
on vous présente une famille à travers
une mère et sa fille qui en a fait un
mode de vie depuis des décennies dans
une région où les hivers sont rigoureux
elles ont même écrit un livre pour
accompagner ceux qui seraient tentés par
l'aventure
[Musique]
pour moi l'auto-suffisance c'est faisait
le moins possible sur la planète en
général puis sur les autres
êtres humains c'est une question
d'équité envers l'environnement
mi-novembre l'un des derniers jours de
récolte à la ferme des thés verts se
fait sous la neige
pour les poireaux c'est pas grave c'est
pour ça que
ils arrivent souvent un dernier dans la
liste avec
avec lequel il reste encore lequel puis
lui je suis pas pressé là il va attendre
encore un peu
il a pas peur du froid lequel
presque tous les légumes du jardin de
Marie-Thé et de sa fille Marie sont
entreposés dans ce caveau
certains légumes feuilles posés sur le
sable humide garderont leurs fraîcheur
pendant des mois
au Québec il faut penser à ça parce que
si on veut passer l'année faut trouver
une manière de se garder les légumes
qu'on cultive en été toutes les légumes
d'été qu'on a en trop en fait on les
transforme en lactofermentation pour
l'hiver
quand le caveau est plein on pourrait
croire que la terre tombant dormance
mais les apparences sont trompeuses
l'activité microbienne en fait
bactérienne est très active aussi
l'hiver là donc si c'est pour ça que
c'est important de garder toujours du
païs puis un manteau pour l'hiver pour
que pour que ça gèle pas trop profond
puis que et puis que l'activité puisse
continuer
[Musique]
à la ferme chaque saison amène son lot
de tâches bien défini
[Musique]
1 2 3 au printemps c'est le moment de
semer de repiquer et de renouveler le
paillis c'était pas escouche de verdure
aidera à contrôler les mauvaises herbes
à retenir l'eau et à protéger de
l'érosion
en se décomposant le pays enrichira
aussi la terre mais entre les rangées
d'oignon
quelques mois plus tard au jardin le
contraste est saisissant
mes parents étaient des agriculteurs
petits paysans originaire de France
marithé cultive ce petit coin du
Saguenay depuis 1990 oui j'ai toujours
j'ai toujours aimé ça je sais pas c'est
le contact avec la terre et dehors dans
la nature au milieu des des éléments
pour mariter et sa fille
l'autosuffisance c'est une question de
santé et d'écologie cultiver comment on
fait là ça prend pas d'énergie d'énergie
fossile mais c'est aussi une question
d'équité envers les agriculteurs de la
planète c'est motivant de savoir que tu
peux produire tes affaires puis que tu
vas pas dépendre de d'autres personnes
pour le produit là si on mange des
avocats qui viennent du Mexique ben
c'est les terres des paysans du Mexique
qui sont pris pour manger des avocats et
puis en quoi en quoi ces aliments-là ils
nous reviennent à nous moi c'est là que
j'ai un malais c'est sauf pour se
procurer notamment de la farine ici on
va très peu à l'épicerie presque tout
pousse à deux pas de la maison au total
ce sont près de 200 variétés potagères
qui se côtoient
ma mère voulait nous initier au
jardinage puis chaque enfant avait sa
petite parcelle de jardin avec fallait
qu'on choisisse les légumes qu'on
voulait cultiver qu'on s'en occupe puis
qu'on les met à terme et que à chaque
année on faisait nos expériences et que
moi j'ai juste des bons souvenirs de ça
la famille est établie sur ce terrain de
4000 mètres carrés les trois quarts de
la superficie sont consacrés à la
production alimentaire quelques chèvres
des poules des arbres fruitiers et un
grand jardin fournissent environ la
moitié de l'alimentation annuelle de 5
adultes
manger local en saison réduire son
empreinte écologique la vision de
l'autosuffisance des thévares n'est pas
celle véhiculée dans les discours
politiques
ici on va vraiment manger ce qui pousse
dans cette saison là
en ce moment on mange des concombres et
des tomates mais au mois de janvier on
en mangera pas tu veux manger des
tomates au mois de janvier ou au mois de
février là ben les tomates comme on
comme on les voit juteuses et tout faut
que tu saches que c'est très
consommateur d'énergie
il y a quelques années les thévards ont
adopté une technique qu'on voit rarement
au potager le non travail du sol depuis
2012 on n'a jamais ni bécher ni biné le
sol on fait juste rajouter de la matière
à la surface un peu comme un foret ça
revient dans le fond à éviter le sol
forestier c'est à dire de toujours
couvrir en surface le sol de paillis qui
a personne dans la forêt qui va aller
labourer qui va aller désherber qui va
aller arroser pour pour que ça pousse
mieux en fait
[Musique]
même après la récolte les plans de
haricots ou de tomates par exemple ne
sont pas arrachés on laisse les racines
se décomposer dans le sol
il y a plusieurs strates dans le sol
puis chaque habitant du sol c'est
innombrable la vie que là-dedans ben ils
ont chacun leur
milieu de vie si on veut tiens on le
dérange pas quand on le retourne pas ben
ça va rester là puis le sol il va rester
comme une éponge si on veut le non
travail du sol ça veut dire aussi
limiter l'arrosage quand on plante on
fait un trou au travers le paillis et
puis là on va arroser au moment de la
plantation mais une fois qu'ils sont qui
sont germées ben là on arrose plus ça va
faire que la plante va être plus
autonome s'il y a une sécheresse elle a
déjà son système racinaire plus profond
pour aller chercher de l'humidité en
profondeur
jardiner en autosuffisance ça veut dire
également ne pas dépendre des engrais
extérieurs
le compost qui vient du fumier des
chèvres du fumier des poules les résidus
de table etc et puis aussi du fumier
humain parce que on a des toilettes
sèches on essaye de faire la boucle et
d'avoir le moins de perte possible de
nutriments le fait de tout redonner au
sol dans le fond c'est un peu logique si
tu vois le sol comme un réservoir puis
que tu enlèves toujours de la matière il
s'épuise c'est purement logique tout le
monde connaît le principe avec son
compte de banque tous les fumiers sont
composés en andain sur une période assez
longue pour détruire les bactéries et
éviter la contamination mais il faut au
préalable vérifier la réglementation
dans sa municipalité chez les thés verts
au fil du temps ces apports de
nutriments ont grandement amélioré la
fertilité du sol
on avait fait une analyse de sol au
début des années 2000 pour voir un peu
qu'est-ce qu'il y avait dans le sol ici
puis on avait un sol généralement pauvre
pauvre en phosphore si on est sur
l'argile lourde puis on a refait une
autre analyse de ça pendant 2019 puis là
on était à côté très riche dans tous les
nutriments y compris le phosphore on n'a
jamais et intégrer dans graisses
chimique et pas de pesticides non plus
au jardin pour minimiser l'impact des
indésirables comme les limaces les
thévares ont créé des habitats pour leur
prédateurs on a installé une mare pour
développer un écosystème avoir des
crapauds des grenouilles etc puis je
laisse traîner des tas de bois dans un
coin du jardin ça a l'air un peu
abandonné mais là-dedans peut y avoir
des couleurs ou toutes sortes d'insectes
qui ou d'animaux de petits animaux qui
trouvent refuge là-dedans finalement je
m'aperçois au fil des années que
vraiment il y a un équilibre qui se fait
un équilibre qui procure à la famille
une belle autonomie la covid par exemple
a eu peu d'entrées ici au niveau
alimentaire ça strictement rien changé
pas de ni dans le prix ni dans quoi que
ce soit
avec en poche un bac en
agro-environnement marie part visiter
des fermes en Europe en 2018 avec le
recul de l'école plus du voyage c'est là
que je commençais à voir que dans le
fond les expériences qu'on faisait ici
ça donnait vraiment des résultats par
rapport à ce que je voyais ailleurs avec
très peu d'énergie très peu d'intrants
avec des résultats comme vraiment
impressionnant puis m'est venu comme le
sentiment que il fallait que ça soit
consignée quelque part même je me disais
c'est ma mère qui jardinait
principalement puis moi je connais un
peu le jardin mais je serais pas capable
de le reprendre moi-même toute seule
puis là il s'est mis comme un peu une
angoisse dire ça peut pas se perdre un
livre guide pratique d'autosuffisance
alimentaire paru en 2021
de ce désir de transmettre ce savoir
mais est-ce que ce mode de vie équivaut
à tourner le dos à la modernité
c'est pour retourner en arrière parce
que on tombe pas en arrière de toute
manière le temps il avance vers en avant
et puis aujourd'hui on a accès à
beaucoup plus de variétés de semences
différentes
c'est quand même une chance parce qu'on
peut se connecter entre paysans entre
jardiniers puis discuter c'est avant
quand tu avais un problème de ravageur
si pouvait pas aller sur facebook puis
avoir 120 réponses à une demi-heure
c'est sûr que tu es pas toujours sûr
c'est quoi la bonne réponse mais au
moins tu peux parler à des gens tu sais
l'accès à l'information générale Google
Scholar les études scientifiques
je pense que l'information ça change
vraiment la donne par rapport à nos
ancêtres
ça rapporte une contrainte de manger les
aliments saisonniers puis d'être dans
son jardin au moment où ça pousse puis
au moment de récolter mais c'est ça qui
fait partie de la connexion aussi c'est
à ce moment-là qu'on s'en connecter
et malgré les efforts qu'il faut y
mettre selon elle le résultat n'a pas de
prix je sais la qualité d'alimentation
qu'on mange ici c'est juste impossible à
acheter mais le fait de le cueillir
juste avant de le manger ça ça s'achète
pas
[Musique]
il me rend le plus fier c'est de réussir
à produire une nourriture saine d'avoir
élevé mes enfants avec avec cette
nourriture là d'avoir des enfants quand
même enfants et puis d'avoir réussi à ce
que les enfants soient intéressés par ça
aussi
c'est ici que j'habite puis c'est
territoire-là qui me nourrit je fais
partie de cette écosystème là mais que
je me dis que en faisant partie d'un
écosystème j'ai mon environnement qui me
nourrit puis que je nourris aussi puis à
ce moment-là c'est ma juste place que je
prends dans le monde